okay das ist gut das ist gut dass es
sehr gut dass es das ist
das war doch nicht so gut
mein name ist herzlich willkommen wir
heute meine damen und herren zu einer
neuen folge happy meals in der letzten
folge habe ich euch gesagt dass ihr mir
level einreichen sollte unter dem namen
laser luca von daher schauen wir mal was
dazu alles an kam also ich gebe einfach
mal laser luca ein klicke auf search und
wir sehen schon wir haben 1 2 3 4 5 6 7
8 level die eingereicht wurde die wurden
schon teilweise 5500 mal gespielt
okay let's go ich würde sagen wir fangen
wir mit dem level an das am wenigsten
male gespielt wurde und zwar elfmal ms
laser luca bottle flip hallo luca dieses
ein bottle flip level du musst eine
flasche hinter die mit leertaste greifen
und sie werfen die flasche muss auf gott
hinter die landen um zu gewinnen viel
spaß und glück ja mal schauen wie viel
glück ich haben werde also als erstes
müssen wir hier ein charakter auswählen
er mich würd sagen ich nehme einfach den
hier und ich kann leertaste drücken und
dann passiert
nichts außer dass ich meine hände
bewegen ich habe allerdings auch noch
die pfeiltaste nach hinten dann greife
ich schon mal nach hinten jetzt
leertaste gedrückt halten und jetzt sagt
er genau noch mal das ganze also nach
hinten greifen lehrers und zack da bin
ich ein paar sekunden später
ich hab ich ja diese flasche beschreiben
mein leben in einem bild aber wären wir
noch mehr versuche das heißt ich bin ich
[Musik]
habe es geschafft mir beide beine zu
brechen
ja herzlich willkommen bei happy meals
mit luca allerdings war der lieben
freund ich würde sagen wir ries daten
das ganze level jetzt einfach mal reifen
wieder nach hinten und machen das gut
das ist bin ich so beschissen ja ich
greife wieder nach hinten drücken so
okay das ist gut das ist gut dass es
sehr gut dass es das ist
das war doch nicht so gut ich komme
nicht an die flasche bin ich bin ich so
schlecht weg
ich habe ja bevor der anfang noch
schlimmer wird würd ich sagen stützt uns
direkt ins nächste level also das level
von maxi fisch war auf jeden fall ganz
lustig das nächste level es von hunt 33
37 und das heißt das ist mein erstes
will alles klar
wenn du nicht mal das wort level richtig
schreiben kannst dann weiß ja was wir
befinden uns hier im level und hier
steht lukas ist der coolste youtuber dem
das level nicht zu ernst ich habe mir
extra um die ein level zu bauen einen
account erstellt dies ist mein erstes
level okay das ja schon mal cool an wir
erfahren wir hängen fest
hier hängt doch nicht fest ob er weiter
geht's leute ab ich hab keinen kopf mehr
also schauen wir mal ob wir das ganze
noch mal hinkriegen beziehungsweise ob
das überhaupt hinkriegen also hier fahre
ich habe mir meinen ich hab mein bein
gebrochen
ich hab' ich habe
ja das sieht jetzt auch nicht so bequem
aus da vorne steht geweckt ich muss
packen und ein typ der neben einer
mülltonne auf dem post also ich ja da
sieht man was die lupe wirklich für
fantasien wieder wieder hat hier aber
wir fahren weiter nach vorne er macht
die kette mit deinem booster pack ich
habe mir nur noch mein zweites verein
nicht nur gebrochen sondern ich habe
auch mal einen fuß verloren aber ich
würde sagen wir müssen ein bisschen an
schwung nehmen also hallo ich aber mein
fuß liegt auf der torte also wir müssen
auf jeden fall ein bisschen mehr an
schwung nehmen also okay das haben wir
geschafft
mit schön hier das ist berüchtigt ist
ganz mit fantasie geben will
kann ich mich einfach normal spielen ich
habe mich mal ich glaube ich kommt nicht
jetzt er irgendwie hab ich gesagt
weitergeht und wie komme ich jetzt aber
hallo ich habe ein schwert in meiner
kniescheibe stecken
ich hab erschwert
ja ich würde sagen wir machen weiter mit
dem nächsten der will das nächste level
laser luca don't move halle luca dieses
bereits mein drittes level welches sich
hochgeladen habe okay es ist ein
download level dies bedeute dass du dich
nicht bewegen darf schon automatisch zum
ende kommt das hört sich so an als würde
sogar ich dass wir hinkriegen können
also ich klicke jetzt einfach wirklich
gar nichts
der fahrradfahrer bewegt sich mein kind
ist tot ich fliege mit dem kopf und dem
blut meines kindes über die teile mein
kind ist komplett weg
ich fahre und fliege weiter und ich
liege um das hat ja super geklappt dass
ich mich da nicht bewegen soll das
nächste level ist von laser luca ist
cool
in der beschreibung steht luca wenn du
das schaffst bist du übels krass level
ist möglich also dass er will heute auf
jeden fall so schwer an wenn du kriegst
du eine luca pizza 33 meine damen kommt
demnächst raus entweder ende november
noch oder am ersten zwölfter also geht
doch
ich hab nichts bedeutet also wir fahren
erst mal ein bisschen nach vorne und
jetzt sind wir direkt hier sind
unser herz lebt noch ich gebe dem ganzen
jetzt nochmal einen letzten versuch ich
fahre ganz langsam hier vor muss ich ja
ich bin ich nehme doch ich lieber gott
ich bin tot
ich lebe ich lebe immer noch oh mein
gott ich kann auch push geben oh mein
gott das ist jetzt nicht hat
ja nächstes level dieses levels von dem
user mister meine lockt ein selbst
ausgedacht das spiel modus wenn es schon
mal so was in der art gab dann keine
ahnung aber es geht darum über die
spikes zu jumpen also müssen wir die
spikes jumpen das heißt ich springe und
sind total also riester hat mir das
ganze level mal wir springen wieder nach
vorne habe mich halt mich jetzt aber wir
können es ja das erste level dass wir
heute abgeschlossen haben
komme ich nun allerdings schon zum
dritten mal gespielten level mit fast
1000 playgrounds halle luca du wolltest
dass die lupe happy with devils für dich
macht viel spaß an wirklichen direkt auf
play now und radeln einfach mal los in
meinem kleinen kind von dir vorne lag
mein kind ist mein bein ist gebrochen
da ist eine abrissbirne ein paar
sekunden später wieso fliege ich hallo
wollte wollt ihr mich verarschen
warum fähig ich gebe dem ganzen noch im
letzten versuch vielleicht überlegt ja
diesmal auch mein kind und das ist schon
wieder tot
und jetzt ist es komplett weg aber das
hält uns natürlich nicht davon
warum bin ich gestorben
aber gut meine lieben freunde wir kommen
zum 21 gespielten level auch von dem
user maxi fisches hat über 1000
playground luca dies ist mein zweites
leben ich hoffe dir gefällt ist denn ich
habe mehrere stunden dran gesetzt ok ich
fange mal hier runter und zu dem ich
mein kind schon wieder tot justus kannst
du
einmal das level überleben aber okay
dann schaffen wir das halt ohne justus 1
fahrer nochmals schöne bei denen drüber
schoss wir so weitermachen kurz media
nicht zu blöd für diese spiele schauen
wir mal das letzte level an konsole kmk
ist das level viel spaß in einem fall
will ich hoffe es gefällt die also ich
denke einfach mal auf play now es hat
die meisten playground mein gott
[Musik]
ist das denn
das kann doch niemals von der lupus 1
guckt euch mal an was das leveldesign
ist aber okay wir versuchen das ganze
jetzt einfach mal hinzu ich dem tod ich
war jetzt einfach mal in die andere
richtung fly okay hier nach hinten geht
nichts das heißt ich habe da noch vorne
war diesmal ach so ich darf den ah ok
das ding auf meinem kopf ist glaube ich
eine bombe oder so ich es noch nicht so
ganz also das teil auf meinem kopf ist
irgendwie hatte ich jetzt ich lass euch
jetzt mal ganz kurz dran also ich weg
auf restart level solche glaube es gibt
weil das haben wir gerade schon gesehen
nichts und betont ich glaube das liegt
daran weil dieses komische teil
irgendwie denn dieser kommune berührte
das ist irgendwie so eine bewegungs
bombe also ich denke es gibt und ich war
direkt nach hinten das teil berührt
nicht okay wir leben noch
wie schaffe ich das jetzt ich war mal
ganz langsam nach vorne hier dran vorbei
okay das hat mir hingekriegt jetzt hier
vorne lang nach vorne liegt eine axt
die darf ich nicht berühren das heißt
springen
lasst mich in ruhe mit diesen scheiß
leveln anderer stelle möchte sollte
wieder solvent meine lieben freunde
werden die nächste folge happy meals mit
eurem level kommen wollt dann erstellt
mir gerne level zungen bei den laser
luca dann seid ihr vielleicht der
nächsten folge dabei dass ein daumen
hoch darunter dem video wenn es euch
gefallen hat und ich hab ne pizza ofen
[Musik]